INTRO:
We all know Kraft-Heinz as the legacy food
brand in supermarkets.
From their various condiments to their cheese
and ready made meals, Kraft-Heinz is one of
the biggest names in food.
Yet, despite their dominant status amongst
the grocery aisles, Kraft-Heinz isn’t actually
doing that well.
Their last few quarters have been hit or miss
in terms of profit, they were recently exposed
for an accounting scandal, and their stock
is down over 50% from their 2017 highs.
You would think that the top investors would
stay miles away from this company, but ironically,
one of the biggest investors in Kraft-Heinz
is Warren Buffett.
As you would guess, Kraft-Heinz has been one
of Buffett's worst investments of all time.
Buffett has admitted that he did overpay for
the Kraft portion of the business, but he
has no plans of selling.
It should be noted though that Buffett owns
26% of Kraft-Heinz, so he really has no easy
way out in terms of selling that large of
a stake.
So, his decision to hold may have more to
do with a lack of liquidity than an optimistic
outlook for Kraft-Heinz.
This brings up the question, what even happened
to Kraft-Heinz and can they actually recover
like Buffett is hoping?
THE COMING OF KRAFT-HEINZ:
Taking a look back at the history of Kraft-Heinz,
the company’s story actually dates back
over a 100 years to 1876 to a man named Henry
John Heinz.
Henry was born to German immigrants and was
determined to achieve the American Dream.
So, at age 33, he began a small food business
with his cousin and brother.
Just like today, Heinz was basically synonymous
with ketchup in the late 1800s given that
this was their first product.
While the company performed well under Henry’s
leadership, it never became a food behemoth
or anything.
It wasn’t until Henry’s son, Howard, took
over and the great depression hit that Heinz
really took off.
You see, when money was extremely tight, Heinz’s
ready to eat meals and cheap condiments were
an indispensable part of the average American's
diet.
By the time America recovered from the Great
Depression, Heinz had become a staple amongst
grocery stores, and it was just a matter of
scaling and maintaining their dominance.
In terms of Kraft’s side of the business,
their history also dates back 100 years to
1909.
Like Heinz, Kraft was also a family business
started by a Canadian immigrant.
James L. Kraft and his brothers started off
as door to door cheese salesmen.
Not only were they good salesmen, but they
were also phenomenal cheese producers.
In 1916, they figured out a new method to
pasteurize cheese that gave their cheese a
significantly longer shelf life.
They went ahead and patented this technique
which gave them an edge over the competition,
but when they received an acquisition offer
that was too good to refuse, they went ahead
and sold their company to National Dairy Products
Corporation in 1930.
The Kraft brand was mainly just a subsidiary
for the next 39 years until National Dairy
decided to revive the brand by renaming the
parent company Kraftco corporation in 1969.
19 years after this, in 1988, General Mills
would acquire the Kraft Brand and they would
hold onto it for the next 19 more years.
It wasn’t till 2007 that General Mills started
to sell off Kraft on the public markets which
finally made it an independent company once
again.
8 years later, in 2015, the boards of both
Kraft and Heinz approved a merger in an attempt
to create a food giant.
But, they ended up creating a food disaster,
so what went wrong?
GENERIC BRANDS:
Likely one of the biggest factors holding
back Kraft-Heinz is the boom of super retailers
like Walmart, Sam's Club, and Costco.
As these guys grow larger, they have started
to directly compete with suppliers.
For example, Walmart has Great Value, Sam’s
Club has Member’s Mark, and Costco has Kirkland.
If you’re not familiar with these brands,
they’re comparable to generic brand medicine.
They basically go out and copy all of the
most popular products within their stores.
And, given that such retailers have insane
economies of scale and in house production
capacity, they can usually offer the same
products for substantially less.
For instance, here’s the official Oreos
and Great Value’s Oreos side by side.
While these are basically the same product,
Great Value’s offerings are almost half
the cost.
A 19.1 oz packet of Oreos clocks in at $3.98
while a 19.1 oz packet of Great Value Oreos
costs $2.08.
Now of course, many people including myself
will always just go with the legacy brand,
but a good portion of people won’t really
care.
Not only does this drive revenue away from
legacy food brands, but it forces these brands
to be more competitive with price which shrinks
their profit margins.
Now, this is great news for consumers, but
for name brands who already have meager profit
margins, such competition can easily push
them into unprofitability.
Fortunately, Kraft-Heinz themselves have pretty
large operations meaning that they can put
up a good fight against generic brands.
But, with that being said, such competition
has shrunk their net margins down to the single
digits.
Aside from diminishing margins, the truth
is that Kraft-Heinz doesn’t actually have
that much room to grow.
While the company has made several acquisitions
to try to continue growth, this hasn’t been
exactly successful.
At the end of the day, Kraft and Heinz are
still only known for the two products that
they were founded on cheese and ketchup.
And the problem is that they’ve basically
reached market saturation within these sectors.
After all, their products are already dirt
cheap and available everywhere in the US,
so anyone who wants these products can easily
get them.
Considering this, I don’t think you’d
be surprised to hear that their revenue has
flatlined at $25 to $26 billion for the past
6 years.
Their revenue also has basically 0 volatility.
Their best and worst 12 month periods within
the past 6 years are within 7% of each other.
And while this may be great for stability,
it’s absolutely garbage for growth.
HEALTHY TRENDS:
Now, you might be thinking, with the introduction
of in house generic brands, it’s basically
impossible to break into the food industry.
And while this is partially true given that
the food industry is extremely brutal and
cutthroat, one sector of the industry has
been growing rapidly, and that’s healthier
options.
Usually within any market, you have your bougie
sector.
With cars, you have Mercedes and Audi.
With smartphones, you have Apple and Samsung.
And with food, you have organic options and
Whole Foods.
While this portion of the market is substantially
more profitable, the size of this market is
generally much smaller.
If you want to grow the biggest business possible,
it’s usually better to target the rest of
the market, and that’s exactly what Kraft
and Heinz have both been doing for over a
100 years.
But the problem is that this strategy only
works up until a certain point.
Once you’re under a price point which consumers
deem fair, they start to make their buying
decision based on other factors like health.
Now, this isn’t to say that the average
person is all of sudden strictly buying organic
foods from Whole Foods.
But, the average person has trended towards
buying foods with less preservatives, less
processing, and more natural ingredients.
And Kraft-Heinz’s offerings are basically
the antithesis to this trend.
In fact, if anything, their products have
historically become more processed as they
try to keep up with the prices of generic
brands.
Over the past few years, they have shifted
their focus onto the health trend.
For example, their newer mac and cheese boxes
proudly state that they have no artificial
preservatives, no artificial flavors, and
no artificial dyes.
However, this hasn’t been all that successful.
First of all, Kraft-Heinz was late to this
trend which gave consumers ample time to find
alternatives.
And secondly, Kraft-Heinz can’t just change
their association with processed foods which
has been ingrained in consumers’ minds for
literally a century with a simple marketing
campaign.
Likely the best option for Kraft-Heinz was
acquiring up and coming brands that aren’t
held back by this association, but they’ve
screwed this up pretty badly as well.
INTERNAL AFFAIRS:
The first acquisition that didn’t particularly
help the company was the merger of Kraft and
Heinz itself.
Not only did Heinz likely overpay for Kraft
like Warren Buffett suggested, but there was
really no reason to complete the merger in
the first place.
The idea was that Kraft and Heinz could share
manufacturing facilities and marketing efforts
in order to lower costs and reach an even
larger audience.
But as we just discussed, lower prices aren’t
exactly what consumers even want.
So, all this merger did was lock in Kraft-Heinz
on a cost reduction journey that didn’t
need to take place.
And to make things worse, given how interconnected
the two companies are now, it’s even harder
for them to switch paths compared to if they
were just independent companies.
Also, it’s not just me who thinks that this
acquisition was not the best.
Kraft-Heinz themselves admit that this was
a poor merger which is evident in how they
wrote off Kraft and Oscar Mayer as a $15 billion
loss.
This write off was followed by a dividend
reduction of 36%, And just when you think
things can’t get worse, Kraft also announced
that they were under investigation by the
SEC for their accounting practices.
Unfortunately, this investigation would result
in evidence that Kraft-Heinz was indeed engaging
in accounting misconduct.
Between 2015 and 2018, Kraft had recognized
unearned discounts from suppliers and maintained
false and misleading supplier contracts.
This allowed them to understate their expenses
and overstate their profit.
By the end of the investigation, Kraft had
to correct a total of $208 million worth of
bogus cost savings and they were fined a total
of $62 million.
During such tough times, you would hope that
the leadership at the company was strong and
had a game plan.
But this wasn’t the case either.
In April of 2019, the CEO, Bernardo Hees left
the company at the peak of their troubles.
It should also be mentioned that his time
as CEO wasn’t that great either.
His legacy at Kraft is literally firing thousands
of employees in an effort to cut costs.
So, clearly, Kraft–Heinz hasn’t been doing
that great internally or externally for several
years.
BAGHOLDING:
Despite all these shortfalls, Warren Buffett
still believes that both Kraft and Heinz are
wonderful businesses, and that their main
mistake was simply overpaying for Kraft.
With that being said though, the only reason
he still has a position in the company is
because it’s not easy to get out.
Buffett said quote, “We can't as a practical
matter move around tens of billions of dollars
that easily.
But beyond that I mean, if we're working with
a million dollars or $10 million, would I
have a position in it?
No.”
And I think this tells us everything we need
to know about what Buffett really thinks about
the future of the company.
He wouldn’t invest in it right now, but
since he already has a position, he’s hoping
to see it through which is quite possible.
It’s been some time since the merger happened
and the pandemic started which has allowed
Kraft-Heinz to regain profitability.
Their profits are still low compared to what
they used to be which is leading to a high
PE ratio of 67.
But, as their profits continue to recover,
this number should only go down.
Also, Kraft-Heinz may be able to bump up their
dividend again which could attract a lot more
interest into the stock.
All of these factors could help Kraft-Heinz
stock return to their all time highs and potentially
even beat their highs.
But, given all of the underlying issues that
we’ve discussed so far, I think Kraft-Heinz
will have a difficult time growing much further
than that.
But that’s just what I think.
Why do you guys think Kraft-Heinz is performing
so badly?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’ve ever had their
ketchup or their mac and cheese.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.